section on Senate Bill 207
just kind of a review this is the one
establishes wants to establish a
committee to study it
and then there's
um
some language
about emergency medical and Trauma
services and
um
and as I understand it the uh
the intent is to have them covered by at
least what we heard covered by as I
understand at workman's comp and that
somehow that was gonna
provide liability protection and um and
you know let them maintain
confidentiality about you know the
people who are providing counseling with
the people they're counseling and the
questions I had during the public
hearing
was it wasn't clear to me I mean I'm I
support that but it wasn't clear to me
looking at the bill
and the statute how the language in this
bill
actually provides
um
you know liability protection as well as
a confidentiality so if there's anybody
foreign
Mr chair members of the subcommittee for
the record my name is Brian rill I'm the
president of the professional
firefighters in New Hampshire
how's the last name spell
r-y-l-l uh all right
and
um first and foremost I would like to
apologize to the members of the
subcommittee I was uh unavailable to be
present at the full committee executive
session on this to clear up any
confusion which uh it was clear that
that's the direction it went was it was
nothing but confusing uh so that's
that's my fault and I apologize
um I will start by saying the intent of
this uh Bill and I'm only speaking to
part two of the bill we have nothing to
do with part one part two is the
um
the addition of the peer support groups
and whatnot underneath the current RSA
the intent of this
was to just expand upon post-traumatic
stress disorder and resources here in
the state of New Hampshire so
um it's no surprise and and just a quick
statistic uh 20 of firefighters
um will at some point uh be diagnosed
with some form of post-traumatic stress
disorder or acute stress disorder and
that's from the The Academy of
psychology so that's uh That's the basis
for why this is so important uh in 2015
the International Association of
firefighters so I mean hang on yes I'm
looking I mean we heard testimony on
that I mean and also if anybody in the
committee also has questions let me know
but
I'm looking for an answer for a
technical question okay which is we
heard testimony that passing this bill
would provide the liability protection
and let the uh you know people providing
the peer counseling maintain
confidentiality precisely how does
passing this do that you know very good
thank you for your question I am unsure
of that because again that was not the
intent of why we submitted it
um some folks came up and tried to do
some explanation and I think it just
over complicated things if if you would
allow I'll explain the actual intent of
of that piece of the legislation under
the current RSA
it states that
um
make sure I get it right here so a
critical incident stress management team
means the group of one or more trained
volunteers and which RSA are you uh that
and this is and I'm I'm reading you can
read it straight from the amendment and
uh I'll just leave out the parts that
are looking for Amendment but
essentially a critical instance stress
management team in New Hampshire has to
be organized by a unit of State local or
County government to simplify it uh the
teams that we have established in the
state of New Hampshire
for the professional firefighters of New
Hampshire
are not organized by a unit of local a
unit of State local or County Government
this bill is intended to just expand
that slightly and allow our organization
the professional firefighters of New
Hampshire
to utilize their peer support services
their peer support group which has been
recognized by the commissioner of safety
in a letter that you have in front of
you
uh
to allow for the protections under this
RSA much like any other critical
incident stress team in the state
so this does two things
it expands that language
because a union organization is not
organized by state local or County
government so it expands it to allow our
Union to provide peer support services
to our members
and what that does is it affords us the
protections under confidentiality uh
further down in
the statute where's that you can see it
under
3A 150s three dash a
so 153
a17 a
and it would be 3A
any information hang on sorry what's the
RSA so it's the same RSI I'm rating 53-a
yep
all right 17 colon uh colon seven colon
17. all right hang on all right there it
is a
and then under there 3A Roman three yep
Roman three okay just give me a moment
thank you
all right any information involves the
team or team member
okay
so all this is looking to do current
critical incident stress teams in the
state
are afforded the protection to have
anything divulged to them in their work
as confidential so that they're not
required to testify or have any third
party administrative hearing where they
have to share the information
yeah and the other thing that was
mentioned I don't know if it was correct
and that's good because that
the person who spoke at the public
hearing was was talking about being
somehow under workman's comp or
something which didn't make any sense
but I see this here thank you for that
sure
um and also we heard that it provided
some kind of liability protection
for um you know the the team and is that
correct and if so where's that in
statute so I think no is the easy answer
um I think there may have been some
confusion in words between liability and
confidentiality basically it affords
them the protection of the
confidentiality
um which I guess you could interpret as
uh a liability but there's no
um there's this is a no cost item
um it's it's recognized already our team
is recognized by the commissioner of
safety he was supportive of this change
but just was didn't have the authority
uh to make it on his own honestly and
and the other piece to this is just
defining because if you look in again
going back to the 153 a17 under number
seven where it defines a critical
incident stress management team hang on
a moment so that's 153 a17
yeah it is it is under the amended bill
right here
uh number seven okay section seven okay
yep uh it and then uh under a critical
incident stress management team means
the group of one or more trained
volunteers including members of a peer
support group peer support group is not
currently defined anywhere in statute uh
so the second piece of this if you look
below uh to F is just defining peer
support group so that
it further encompasses the intent of of
the the protections under this law
okay and so I mean under the bill
currently it looks like it refers to as
critical incident stress management
uh Team yep and it says means the group
of one or more trained volunteers
including members of peer support groups
but nowhere and current statute does it
State what a peer support group actually
is all right thank you anybody else in
the committee have questions
I mean that that clears up my confusion
and concern so thank you for that sure
um
thank you yeah
now the other thing on the and I I mean
part two on this I'm I completely
support
um
I know uh
when I you know generally are not big
fans of
the committee the first part that sort
of thing the first part
um
creates and
representative McGuire had an amendment
that
just took out the study commission and
left everything else in that's that's
you're okay with that yes okay any other
comments on that
sure
thank you Mr chairman my my question is
so the amendment takes out the study
so the question about the workers comp
and how this all works I'm just unsure
like how the bill breaks in half I guess
it's a logistics question well I think
what we just heard is that the person
who brought the workman's comp-up thing
during the public hearing basically
misspoke
and that has nothing to do with
workman's comp
that it's actually in further down in
the statute which I hadn't read I didn't
get that far down in it of 153
um
yeah I believe
a17 and the part we were just going over
and if you look at it it deals with the
confidentiality thing in there it's it's
uh very clear so that satisfied my
concern that my concern was that I
supported what they want to do my
concern was the Bill didn't
seem to do what the person was talking
about so so I think and they're
completely separate so there's no
establishing the study committee
is not related to the rest of the bill
so they're basically independent
what's up do you turn your mic on you
can talk
thank you Mr chairman so is it my
understanding then
because of the confusion because of the
amendment do is it
just we're not really making any
progress here this is not already I
disagree um my intent is to make a
motion first to adopt the amendment
which gets sort of the study committee
and then
um you know I'd be glad to accept or
make you know an otpa motion on the
underlying bill
um so we would remove the study
committee part from the bill and keep
the
the part we were just discussing that
that puts these peer support groups in
statute and therefore they get
some Treasury and rights in particular
the confidentiality part so
no I'm not no please have a seat
if we have questions we'll ask it's not
this is not a public hearing
I mean if there's a reason to him yeah
Mr chairman I think that as the chairman
has suggested this is pretty simple
we're getting rid of the study committee
but we're leaving the rest of it in here
because it does provide some definitions
and some protections it doesn't cost a
dime and this is just a good thing to
have it's it's a place where these peer
support groups were not really laid out
in the rsas this basically takes care of
that so it's it's I look at it as more
of a housekeeping thing than anything
else and providing more support to fire
services and professionals that are out
there working in you know fire police
whatever they're working out there in
any other you have any questions on this
yeah do you still have
questions on this
okay thank you and uh sorry for not
calling on people but uh
you know unless somebody's here opposing
uh the idea
turn the mic on please sit down and then
introduce yourself it's this is being
recorded and and uh
no you have to push the there you go yep
you have to speak into the mic pretty
much yes uh good morning Mr chairman
members of the subcommittee uh my name
is David Goldstein I'm the chief of
police in the city of Franklin I've been
a police officer for 44 years I've been
doing this kind of work for more than
that time I actually have a PhD in the
subject uh and we're a little bit
concerned with some of the language that
we're seeing here uh and I am a member
of Senator bird sales commission on PTSD
as it relates to workers comp
so I think that there may be some
questions that I may be able to answer
as well for you but one of our biggest
concerns right now is that the language
in hb2 is different than the language in
the amendment recommended Amendment uh
as far as some of this is concerned
so uh we unfortunately and I apologize
we did not know that this hearing would
be going on our information was that it
was going to be suspended for some
period of time but uh here we are any
questions that I may be able to answer
I'd be happy to do so I also chair the
chief's legislative committee okay
um I was unaware there was anything
related to this in hb2 yes sir
um
if you look at hb2 and this was as
amended by the house presumably
was it it was it an HP presumably it was
an hb2 has passed by the house that is
um okay and I'll just look for Do you
have a
a section number where it is I I do uh
there are a couple uh again it's under
153-a colon 17- small a
which I think you've already been aware
of yeah yeah I just trying to find it in
hb2 as well which is a month and it
would be paragraph e and G that we look
a yeah I didn't bring my copy of hb2
because I didn't realize this would
become an issue
um
T Dash a
okay I've I'm seeing the part where um
it's Section 133
yes the one you're talking about okay
so
Mr chairman yep
a question um the amendment number that
we're looking at can I just have that
remember it's 1291 H thank you and
really the amendment number just
duplicates part two of the bill and so
it doesn't include the first it replaces
the whole bill
it includes part two and everything
Beyond everything else basically
um which is part two and then uh the
effective date so
I'm just
looking and there is language that looks
very similar in hp2 which I don't think
any of us were aware of
um and so
so what
um if you can point out what it where is
their conflict well our conflict
originally comes from section e
under a 133 credential critical
incidence Stress Management where it
talks about employee organization
in hb2 whereas in the amendment I have
anyway
uh under Senate Bill 207 it says or
members of a union of Emergency Response
Public Safety workers as defined by RSA
281a2 so we we're a little bit concerned
with the right contradiction if there
was a choice of I mean are you okay with
the language that's in hb2
um
we're a little bit concerned by that
because we don't know what that
so or employee organizations the concern
about so that could be anything Mr
chairman that could be the janitors and
and please I'm not disrespecting
janitors that could be the janitors
Union at a school okay
all right
um
and just to add to that if you
statutorily now DPW workers are now
defined statutorily as First Responders
so we're we're a little bit concerned
with with the lack of definition if you
will
okay
um
and our uh are you okay with the
language that's in the amendment or do
you see problems there as well the
amendment has a little bit more strength
to it yes a little bit more bite and we
we would if we were forced to choose I
would I would say we'd probably go with
the amendment and but I mean if you had
um
you know what would be your preferred
language
our preferred language would actually be
to have a definition and I believe the
previous speaker brought up the fact
that there are some definitions lacking
but we would like a definition of what
what is meant by that uh
I'm not sure what they mean by Union of
okay
um okay just a moment so uh folks on the
committee
I'm
what we could what I would like to
suggest is that um
we ask
um Mr Goldstein and anybody else
interested if they have suggested
language for those definitions and then
we would I mean we've got two weeks I
think before it's going to be exact
didn't want to drag people up here again
but we could have
um
a subcommittee meeting to go over that
and you know tweak it if need be and
come to an agreement and we can have an
amendment a different Amendment drafted
I I fully agree I think that's the thing
to do is get some suggested amount you
know wording yes for getting that
correction within the amendment that we
have here we would be happy to get that
taken care of I was unaware of the sb2
thing as well that would have come
through my division but I wasn't here at
the time I think so uh certainly it's um
that would be the most easiest way to do
and we'll come back thank you any
comments we are we all uh representative
Bears hey bear
thank you Mr chairman I want to thank
you very much for shedding some light on
this my pleasure all right and can you
um just send the committee well
send us an email on
just outlining the concerns you just had
pointing out the section in hb2 and then
um
you know taking this amendment which I
assume you've looked at and and suggests
some changes to it which we can look at
we would be delighted to do that okay
um is there anybody else who have any
different issues with this who's here
with uh
207.
all right see none I'm going to close
the subcommittee work session on SB 207
organized here a little bit
all right and then I'm going to open the
subcommittee work session on SB 106.
so
I'll tell you what I was thinking then
I'd like to you said you had more uh
later information from representative
okay so what was pointed out by
representative McGuire
is
um
in 170 e colon 50 which is part of the
HHS statute
which is um
chapter 170e is child daycare
residential care and child placement
agencies and
50 is credentialing a Personnel in early
care and education programs I mean
basically it's HHS that does the
regulation of
child care that appears and also I mean
I can read this at Short
but basically it gives
HHS rulemaking Authority
to do whatever
um credentialing so
HHS has as I read this and as chair
McGuire reads this has the authority to
if you can turn the mic on sorry I know
there's somebody here to speak on that
and maybe if she could come up and and
speak on it as well my understanding is
is that there is some conflict between
HHS and education that creates some
confusion in some of this but I think
she can give us better uh if there's
somebody here who can speak to that or
anybody here that can speak to who comes
um
yeah thank you Mr chair and committee
members uh my I am Jay Khan uh former
state senator from Keene and uh someone
who has worked with the Department of
Health and Human Services
uh extensively on this issue
so as I understand your question
specifically right now it is uh
uh related to uh wide
not do this through rules versus doing
this through statute correct because it
looks like 170e colon 50 explicitly
gives
HHS rule making authority to do
precisely what you're looking for
and so I'll disagree with that okay uh
HHS has rule making Authority
and they have developed a set of rules
but they have not in that set of rules
recognized
the department of education's
Career Technical education programs
as
training for the Early Childhood
credentialing
and that is what this is trying to do a
common thing that exists Across the
Nation is that for Early Childhood
there's dual jurisdiction
by Health and Human Services departments
and Departments of Education
and it gets to be complicated
uh to
credential
early educators
and this is trying to transcend that and
and get Beyond it by assuring that the
students who go through training in our
high school Career Technical education
programs
leave those programs within industry
recognized credential that the
Department of Health and Human Services
hasn't touched
so this is and and this has the support
of of the department and their Bureau of
credentialing with Department which the
Health and Human Services I mean has
anyone approached them
about doing this through rulemaking and
is there some legal technical issue why
they can't do it
because it's not clear to me there is I
mean I don't see anything in the stature
that would prevent them from recognizing
graduation from such a CTE program to
um well this is a a specific
charge obviously and we know we know law
Trump's rules right we we know that laws
Trump rules sure uh
this make sure that uh
the intent of the legislature to make
sure that both the Department of
Education and HHS will
have a program that leads to a
credential
for entry into early childhood education
sure I have a question we I thought we
heard that
um doe and the CT program had this
educational program I mean they can't
Grant the credential
but
um that they have the education program
in place
is that not correct correct
they do okay thank you
so it you know we don't need to get them
it sounds like to do anything different
it's just a question of
well I guess my other question is has
anybody actually
approached HHS about
creating such a credential what was the
response uh that this is a good way to
go about it
they were here for the hearing and
supported this effort
they've been very Cooperative in
developing this language I just don't
understand why if the legislature has
already given the authority to do this
they want to have
more stuff in statute to confirm that
and that's not something I would
normally want to do
so I I think you know the basic question
is is there anything really preventing
them from doing it today
one needs to wonder if they was if this
was their intent why has this not been
done
they just recently went through rule
making
and ignored this route
uh
it has not been done uh you you have a
table in front of you I remember was was
and I'd be I brought extra copies of it
of the various credentials that the
department has uh gone through rule
making to establish uh there is an
emerging professional certificate
it does not recognize
the completion of a CTE program okay is
there anyone here from HHS who can speak
to this no
okay thank you
all right
um
I mean if they expressed any up I mean
it seems strange to me that they're
saying they'd like this length in just a
moment oh sorry uh you have a question
is the rub between two agencies
um
Jackie might be a better person I mean I
certainly want to hear what you have to
say but also there's a statute that
explicitly gives HHS The Authority I
don't know if you can how do you do I'm
I'm Jackie Cowell from Early Learning
New Hampshire we're a Statewide
non-profit we Advocate on behalf of
child care programs and professionals
and so we do support this bill because
yes it is true perhaps that that HHS
could do it they haven't done it for
years CTE has been around for a long
time we do think this will strengthen
that and we have to do everything we can
right now to bring Child Care
Professionals into the field and we
think this will strengthen it by having
this law but also
um I think uh Senator former Senator
Khan had mentioned previously if you do
have this credential if it is called
this emerging credential many places
will hire these high school students
right out of this program at higher
salaries with this very particular
credential and I do think it's it's a
statement the legislature would be great
to make even though yes could have been
done perhaps it hasn't been done ever
and it could have been done three years
anybody talked with HHS about this have
they had some reason some objection to
it
no uh there is none and Deb Nelson uh
leads the child care credentialing
Bureau
in HHS she is out on an extended uh
Family Leave medical issue
um
I regret that because obviously but she
has been a partner in this she rewrote
this for the Senate that's what the
nature of the Senate amendment is
um
she recognizes the Gap and and the
effort to to fill the Gap with a
High School
program eventually
um is there someone else who
you know in the department who could
speak to this other than her if she's
here for the hearing
and
he was in support
well I'm not asking that my question is
they have the authority to do it why
have they chosen not to do it that's
um and do they have an email and
is there some reason they're reluctant
to do it or they have some opposition to
it which you say they don't if so why
didn't they do it through rules this
isn't making a lot of sense basically so
do you yeah I I can give you some names
of those folks who could answer that
question for you sure my guess oh so
dot r
as in Roger dot Chase
c-h-a-s-e she's the second in command to
Deborah Nelson and that's at uh at
Legend
and
again what has been historic because
this does to you know connect the
Department of Education my guess is it's
never been done never been talked about
because of those two dual roles
um that they you know that they they
didn't do a rulemaking for
something with Department of Ed but the
fact that they have been very supportive
of this and feeling again like if the
legislature says well how important this
is will help right I mean
you know the Department of Veteran has
the program I don't see why they even
need to be involved
um so having to coordinate it doesn't
maybe there's something I'm missing and
and you know if there's some information
provided that makes it clear why they
cannot do it
um now then you know I might look at
this differently but any anybody else in
the committee have questions for them or
comments yeah yeah you know from my
understanding is this is something this
is not something new this is something
that I guess it was a long-term study
that went on and this is one of the core
recommendations that came out of it to
utilize this program uh Department of
Education so it's been in front of DHHS
for more than a couple years and they
haven't taken any action on it and I
think we're probably all in in wondering
why they have it as well but just
assuming that there is some sort of line
between the two that neither department
wants to cross and that they're here to
you know we're here to basically require
that they cross that line by putting it
into statute so I understand the
reluctance of putting a new statute this
is maybe one place where we have to than
anyone else here just hang on this
yep representative bear
hey there thank you Mr chairman
personally I I like the bill I I like
the idea of bringing more
um willing students that want to get a
certification into the workforce and
um in getting that certification and the
fact that we haven't had a real weigh-in
on why HHS has not done it leads me to
believe that maybe in the middle of
covid over the last three or four years
that everything has fallen to a low
priority and
I like it I'm in support okay
well I mean but education doesn't offer
certification they don't have the
authority it could be given but
yeah
um
so
Mr chairman of my mind something that
might address your concern
um if you'd go to page two of this bill
and line one
uh
and note the kinds of uh
sites that can be used for the clinical
hours
you'll notice that it it it
covers uh licensed Center
licensed center-based Child Care
programs licensed family child care
programs or public
or a private School pre-k through third
grade programs
the public and private School pre-k
programs are not licensed through HHS
that's one of the barriers that there is
in this cross agency issue
this statute says no you will recognize
those Child Care programs in the
school that are School based
and
those hours then will count towards the
certification okay and that's that's a
specific
change that enables the certification to
be comparable in this bill to the rules
that
what I would refer to the committee what
I'd like to suggest we have to get
together again anyway for 207 what I'd
like to do
there's not a real strong objection
would be to
try and get a hold of Diane Chase and
ask explicitly
you know why they haven't done it and
maybe it is this issue and that really
is a legal technical issue in which case
I'd probably be okay with this
um if they have
I mean I just want a clear answer from
HHS as to why they haven't done this and
and maybe maybe it could be they haven't
gotten around to it and now they could
uh maybe there is you know this does
because the presume of the CTE program
allows the clinical to occur in those
places then maybe they can't accept the
CT certificate that could very well be
it and and I would understand that so
yeah sure uh Mr chairman I from my
understanding is that this program will
also this will also help people who may
have and I'm looking at adults more than
kids who may have taken courses in high
school but not gotten into the field and
not been able to complete their style
their requirements and not having to go
back to a a community college system but
being able to use experience where they
may have had years of experience to get
credentialed but they do not have the
college requirements to get credentialed
this would allow them to be credentialed
based on their experience and their and
working in the field we're in the
statute does it say that
well no it's just that people who may
not want to go back to school to get
those things this would give them the
ability how would this bill do that by
allowing them to have uh experience in
these different types of facilities such
as a Child Care Program a licensed
family program
um
right now without going yeah but I think
I think I think that's I think that's
under that would have to be under the
CTE program I don't think this bill
addresses at all the issue of just
general experience well this is maybe
somebody who went through a CTE program
at one point but did not get
credentialed and did not have the
additional training that under current
system you have to get some additional
college credits in order to get in in
order to become certified this would
allow them to utilize experience yeah
I'm skeptical that this will work
because it says they they have to have
500 hours in a Career and Technical
education teacher education program
includes minimum 250 hours of
observation all this other stuff and so
they've got us according to this they
have to have this experience within as
part of a CTE program I don't think
it'll do that at all I mean that might
be a good thing to do
on like you know you know a later bill
but I don't think this will do it
but at least the way I read this
SnapChat Michael advice has been again
has been different from that that's all
from experiment people who my wife is in
the situation and hires these people and
looks at being able to get some people
credentialed that are unable to be
credentialed at the current time
um
yeah actually I might want to talk with
her about that but in fact I'm
representative a bear
uh Mr chairman I had a question off of
Representative grassi's comments would a
high school you know how you can take
um night courses at a high school or
extracurricular is that what that means
well as I read this it would have to be
within a CT program and I don't know if
the CT programs offer night classes to
adults
but I suppose if they did offer that
program that form yeah it could work but
again I mean there's nothing that would
prevent HHS from accepting rulemaking
and I really like to understand why they
haven't done it I mean if maybe
technical stuff that they feel that
there's a legal potential issue and
that's legit
um and then or there may be some other
reason
I I I do want to reiterate the answer is
and and you can call Diane Chase but the
answer is that the high school-based CTE
programs are generally almost
exclusively but I think there's maybe
one or two instances where the CTE
doesn't have a child care center but
offers a certificate program so they
have to go out placement to an HHS
licensed facility
this allows for a not
non-hs licensed facility that a program
that is licensed or permitted through
the Department of Education
to be able to offer those clinical hours
that's what this does and and when the
student goes through these programs and
I I provided that to you earlier too I'd
be glad to provide that what the program
has it has these programs have these
requirements they meet these
requirements and they can deliver people
into the field with both education and
clinical hour experience through the
school-based program
and and the department
can't do that right now okay because
they don't recognize and don't license
the school basis I mean that's that may
very well be the issue in which case I
could support this but I would feel more
comfortable if I talk to uh Diane Chase
talked it over
and you know I mean somebody can make a
motion we could do whatever here but
um you know if that's what's going on
then I'd likely support the bill and I
think
um some other members of the committee
would would be much more likely to
support the bill
if that were clearly answered by HHS
so unless there's and we have to come
back anyway so unless there's an
objection
I'd like to do the same thing as the
other bill is to get some more
information
and take it up again
respect for the chair out of respects
the chair I will not object to that so
but okay thank you
um maybe I'm nitpicky want to be
comfortable with it maybe more and and
uh
and you know if we if we get an answer
if I get an answer I'll let the
subcommittee know and I think if it's
clearly something like this
and then
um you know if we get language to deal
with the conflict with hb2 on the other
bill
um and I can get a proposed amendment
drafted and send it around I think that
um you know if those are true the
follow-up meeting could be quite short
and could even schedule it like at 9 00
a.m before when we exact next you don't
any other comments
Mr chair yeah just one uh I'm not sure
what your version of 106 is but if you
have a version that says in lines one
through ten an amendment to 170 e 11.
this is Page
um on page one one through ten
yeah and 17 by inserting the paragraph
and at
after subparagraph and the following you
know
but a men's RSA 170e colon 11. yep that
was the way this originally came out of
OLS
and that should not be part of this bill
any longer
and why is that because this section of
the statute is relative to the daycare
center licensing day care center
licensing
what begins on line 11 is the amendment
that was asked for by the department
to make sure that this bill amends 170 e
colon 50. okay that is the statute that
is related to credentialing of personnel
not like not centers but Personnel all
right let me take a look
I'm getting mine online and they all say
170 11. yeah so that's how it came out
of the Senate apparently and um on the
first on the first line and then on line
that uh so basically there it is okay I
see it now and it says number two
basically you'd want to remove section
one yes okay
um so we're gonna need Amendment anyway
you do okay okay then that solves that
problem right there I I'm sorry I gotta
fess up here but but that's uh
yeah we have gotten some bills there's
two I mean as a matter by the second
Senate second
let me make sure no they bought yeah
the 170 E11 thing is there
and so this not having this
there's no need for some equivalent
language somewhere else it's not needed
Jake could you get some wording on that
to us please well it sounds like it just
needs the amendment just needs so we
know what it needs to look like exactly
I'll I'll hand this to you okay thank
you but I assume it's just or correct me
if I'm wrong it's just
um
you know take this do an amendment that
removes section one yes right and would
renumber the other sections yes usual
thing
okay and uh yeah if you can give me a
you can actually just scan it at home
email which it's easy all right thank
you and I'm going to close the unless
there's anything else in the committee
I'm going to close the subcommittee work
session on SB 106.
foreign